Mexican Multi multi gajillion air carlos
slim he has floated the idea of a
three-day workweek I think this is
really interesting let's look at some
info he says with three work days a week
we would have more time to relax for
quality of life having four days off
would be very important to generate new
entertainment activities and other ways
of being occupied and now we've got some
info on how he wants to do it the
trade-offs would be longer hours slim
suggested putting in as many as 11 hours
a day and working into later in life
with a call to push the retirement age
back to 70 or 75 he says these changes
would make the labor force more
productive while also making it
healthier and addressing the retirement
crisis many workers face later in life
so I mean this actually sounds pretty
good to me three days a week of work
you're going to work a little bit longer
you're gonna each day and you're gonna
work a little bit later into life I'm
kind of on board this thing and Carlos
Slim this guy knows what he's doing you
don't become the second richest man in
the world by not knowing what you're
doing right in theory theory uh I
definitely think there's some merit to
it but I also think that it is one it's
gonna cut hugely into Walmart's
workforce like hugely that's that we and
we need to address that because I mean
Walmart we need that really young
minimum wage jobs so thank you so the
walmart can get government subsidies de
zactly yeah so that was my main worry
I'm like he's not thinking about the
walmart right what about them um but I
do think there is truth to that when I
am most productive is kind of when I'm
not burned out and there's something to
be said for spending five days you know
traffic five days of traffic and
commuting and all of that stuff could
add into what is a longer day for people
if people could come in and kind of just
work really hard for 11 hours they did
point out that there were problems with
this in terms of you know people who
work in manual labor jobs you know eight
hours is already a lot right 11 hours
would probably kill them so they
wouldn't make it to the retirement age
but that's their problem again right so
part of it does depend what you're doing
because if you're lifting heavy stuff
all day yeah it's gonna be hard to tack
on another three hours but there's a lot
of people that are just sitting at their
computer googling all day right that
aren't that are doing that much you know
the proper youtuber together youtuber
happy to do it so the problem I think in
American I've said this before is that
you know we equate in America with hard
work with bid the harder you work the
better of a person you are which it
there there's no correlation whatsoever
because I don't work at all I'm a great
[ __ ] guy right but I don't that was
that I've scope so there okay why I had
you guys on together wanted to balance
it right its reach its it is it's true i
mean people like like to brag about how
much they work their a hard worker will
work where work a dick we're a bunch
this country is a bunch of adult
children of alcoholics and we don't
recognize our addictions to things and
work is definitely one of them we work
way too much in America you know take a
trip to Spain you know my brother went
to Spain like you can't believe it they
take a nap every day for district get up
yeah and everything somehow everything
gets done in Spain right so I like this
guy's idea think we need to work less
this race to work even more and more and
more and now we gotta we have to compete
with the you know third world countries
and stuff like that I i I'm with them I
say let's try it I'm done working here
you're done working so I 33 days is a
little bit much that I think four is
probably a more reasonable given the
American culture and addiction to work
and the fact that we are an extremely
industrialized country and we want to
stay ahead and we want we have that
drive to be the best be the best I think
it would be very hard to sell oh let's
go down to three days of productivity I
think maybe could push for 40 he's never
gonna sell it it's never gonna happen
it'll never happen but uh you know you
when people in America they're not even
aware of a that people take siestas in
other countries they're not they're not
aware that there's laws in the European
Union for how many hours someone can
work they capped the hours at 48 or 40
in some countries capped that's how much
you can work plus they all get a month
off a year paid every year whether
you're a bartender or waitress or a
doctor or actor Europe yes so they all
is it and they get a lot of them getting
more six to eight weeks off so in
America we're screwed so I would say
let's start with more vague
patient I'm for people that gets on
parallel with the rest of the
industrialized world and then we'll
start scaling back the days when I would
say vacation time so glad you brought a
vacation cuz I think we've done stuff on
this before I think we have something
like the worst literally the worst the
least amount of vacation time in the
industrialized world so we're already
overworked myself and then that was
making me think as i said i just took a
vacation for 10 days that now because we
have these freaking phones you're
working even when you're not working so
now it's like so you really can sup so
whether they say it's three days at the
job or five days at the job we're all
walking around with this thing and can
do work at all times so that makes the
disconnect even that much harder right
just as a last but I'm from a third
world country and my parents when they
started working 20 40 years ago or
however many years ago they were getting
you know four to six weeks of vacation a
year and now that my father is retired
of course he's always vacationing but my
mom vacate has about two months of
vacation a year yeah and what should
country from hey make Jamaica baby wow I
don't know what same diff same day
that's a call back to an earlier segment
folks Jamaica yeah that's a third world
country I didn't know that I've been a
Jamaican I've been to Jamaica to I ok
week that's a whole other story
you